A whale bone.
Joe.
Two Limos.
Fucking
do the Monday morning podcast for lonely.
Um,
June on d suite 2018 what's going on?
How are Ya?
How's your Monday treating you over there in the states?
Uh,
I got my last couple of days over here in Paris.
I'm psyched to come back.
I'm sad that it's over.
I had a wonderful time.
Thank you to everybody over here that put up with my horrible fucking French,
you know?
I know I just,
I just,
I just stayed in the by punished him with at this time.
Okay.
And if they didn't like it,
somebody taught me something to say to him,
just say Ah,
via to stay on.
Cool.
Yay.
That means go fuck yourself.
Vatu Fay.
Cool.
[inaudible] Que Kuli Kuli far que fair on Qa.
Misha.
Wait,
you
ship parlay a bull.
But to fair on que les this year,
you've got to throw in the Mr. Still be polite.
You know what I mean?
You can tell somebody to go fuck themselves over here,
but when you're wearing a scarf,
you got to throw the most year,
you know,
so you don't seem like an animal.
All right.
I learned that it's,
you know,
it's the hardest one to say to say street right over here and it's rue rue.
But you got to go whole oral Santa Ana Ra,
Miss,
yeah.
Two Fe.
Oh,
cool.
Yay.
Q day on Qa.
I'll get it.
I'll get it done.
I'll learn how to say,
go fuck yourself in a new language now.
Right?
Uh,
before we get started,
a very special thanks to a very special person and a wonderful comedian,
uh,
and,
and equally as well human being.
Mr Tom Rhodes for hooking me up,
he found out I was in patty and he was like,
are you still there?
I said,
we,
he said,
I miss you.
You need to go to this fucking Patisserie.
They have the best fucking sandwiches and Blahblahblahblah and God damn it,
the man was right.
Best Sandwiches I've had over here,
maybe top fucking two or three sandwiches I've ever had in my fucking life.
And then I had a one of those little,
how are all those little fucking cookies?
You made a giant one.
It was pistachio.
It was fucking incredible.
You know,
in food.
So good.
You start having tourettes and as you're reading it,
just ah,
fuck shit.
All right.
I was doing that was unbelievable.
Fucking eaten is um,
looking around for people that let them know,
you know,
I know what you're going to say.
What's the name of it?
Bill,
what is the name of the
over there and Perry.
And I only have one thing to say to you far too fair on que les,
I'm not fucking telling you,
cause I don't want to say I don't like standing in lines.
All right?
But Comma,
fucking comedian.
Befriend Tom Rhodes and maybe he'll tell you.
Okay.
But what I ate today was,
was magic.
All right?
And I bet enough around enough magicians in this business to know that you never
revealed the trick.
Okay?
Okay.
Tom Road showed me the trick.
Okay?
It says trick tis.
Fuck.
It says join.
Oh my God,
it was fucking unbelievable.
I walked a mile and a half over there and back.
It's my workout in the morning.
I just go,
I go for a brisk walk,
you know,
I'm starting to learn how to use those little places where people jog along the
Sen.
Uh,
I go down there so I don't have to deal with the fucking giant groups of people
crossing the street to go to the Notradame.
I actually,
we actually went in the,
um,
we went into that church and I'm glad I did it.
The line moves really quickly.
You go in there,
you're like,
wow,
this is echo app girl.
This is huge.
This is scary.
These statues,
um,
not a lot of positive messages in them.
Flood a misery,
lot of death,
a lot of weeping.
But um,
I think that that's just sort of the vibe back then.
I mean,
people just,
people fucking died back then,
you know,
not like tick,
not today.
People just,
they live for fucking ever.
Okay.
You know what I mean?
At my age,
I see somebody died 70.
I was like,
Oh fuck,
what happened?
What did he eat?
No,
it's too,
so,
okay.
Do back then you,
you fucking,
you went outside and like a mosquito bit,
you and then the whole village died the second you sneezed,
everybody was just done,
you know.
And uh,
I believe it was some pompous content that said,
uh,
art imitates life.
So if everybody over there is dying and you're really good with your hands,
when you get the clean it there,
what do you think you're going to make?
You can make some fucking miserable statues,
you know,
I'll tell you these,
these,
these fucking people around here walking around these pasty white kids thinking
that they had goth.
Okay.
Within black nails and lipstick and all of that bullshit.
Let me tell you something.
You got nothing on some of these statutes there and in the Notradame.
Yeah.
So you don't have to say to all,
you got kids out there on two fe
to Oculi.
I fuck it up every time.
Whatever.
That's what you do.
You just punish people with punish people with your fucking,
I ran into some guy with a file,
get where the fuck I was.
Some guy from Washington DC,
the state.
Right.
And,
uh,
and he was talking about trying to learn French over here.
He's living over here.
He said,
it's brutal,
man.
He goes,
they just,
you know,
you try to speak it to them.
Then they just start speaking English.
And I,
and I told him,
I said,
if I go punish him with it,
I don't give a shit.
If they do the whole thing and fucking English,
you stay,
you stay in the pocket.
Right.
Stay on target.
That Star Wars Shit.
Did I tell you guys that white actually on the plane,
I watched one of these plane rides I took,
I watched the owner lows.
One of those star wars movies.
Um,
Laura dern F is for families.
Laura dern was in it.
Um,
the woman who played Princess Leia,
I believe it was the last movie she did before.
Unfortunately she passed away.
Uh,
I don't know who else was in a bunch of young people.
All right.
Kids,
kids to me,
kids to me are under the age of 39 at this point.
And,
uh,
I,
I really enjoyed it and I'd like to apologize to anybody on my list.
Offended at comic con.
Um,
I don't remember what the movie was called.
Oh,
there was an,
uh,
Luke Scott,
Mark Hamill was in it.
Okay.
Right.
And at the end of the movie,
right.
I'm kidding.
Kidding.
Like you nerds haven't watched it 9 million times,
you know,
weeping into a potato sack,
whatever.
You know,
I liked how he was wearing the Ben Kenobi fucking,
um,
like,
you know,
it really,
yeah,
the messages in Star Wars.
Okay.
You know that if you actually live a righteous life,
you know that there's really no money in it.
The way the whole game set up and you end up in like a burlap sack for a
bathrobe just living by yourself.
You know,
making rocks levitate,
you know,
for tourist or whatever the fuck it is he was doing on that island.
But if,
if you sell your fucking soul to the dark side,
you know,
you get that dope ass outfit,
that fucking Darth Vader head,
you know?
Okay.
That looks like some shit.
What's his face?
What a design.
Who's the Coosa designer over here in France.
He used to be fat and now he isn't and all he does is shit on fat people and he
won't make clothes for fat people.
Hey Nia,
what's the name of the designer over here?
He's hilarious.
He used to be fat and now and now we are.
Like I said,
you've been on vacation too long.
Hey Nia on to fail again.
Took code to Qa.
Uh,
I can't remember how you choose cuter late g.F y.
I'm telling too to do that because I know you and you're familiar.
What's the name of that?
Uh,
look.
Robot.
Tarred.
What's his name?
Who's Lou?
Grover died.
I don't know what designer to design.
A white haired guy used to be fat Karl Lagerfeld.
Yeah,
it doesn't Darth Vader
suit look like some shit he'd come up with.
Oh,
for sure.
Yeah,
there you go.
I fucking nailed it.
You're impressed with some of my fashion knowledge.
You've been a,
you've been proving yourself to be quite the passion needs to out here.
I was telling him,
told you the difference between the hoary style and the elegant style,
right?
Yes.
Thanks for explaining that to me.
What do you mean you actually were fascinated by it,
right?
Cause we went to lunch and we were talking about how some of the girls were like
very elegant in some,
you know,
some were all instagrammy he's desperate.
Like they would like basically the fashion version of a comic with the catch
phrase,
right?
Yes,
exactly.
Opposed to me who's all pure up there with my shit and Dick Jokes.
Yeah.
The comedian's comedian.
That's you.
I was going to bust in here and see what you were talking about.
You jerk what's going on?
Uh,
I'll tell you what's going on.
What yesterday for father's Day.
Yay.
My second dose.
A way.
Um,
that way I,
uh,
we went to the,
von caught us [inaudible] we went to the 24 hours of Lamar and uh,
yeah.
How did you enjoy,
I do enjoy it.
Four hours.
Um,
yeah,
but it's not always like that.
Sometimes it's,
sometimes it's,
hmm,
okay.
Yeah,
but like what,
so are you just waiting for somebody to crash or like what's the,
cause it's just round and round.
She goes away,
she stops,
nobody knows.
It's like,
you know,
like it wasn't that exciting.
I mean I know that it's a big,
it's a world famous.
Was it cool to at least see cars going that fast,
that close to each other?
You know,
I feel like I've seen cars goes fast before and it doesn't really
do that much for me.
Um,
me,
this is what,
it's fucking hilarious.
It was father's Day.
I would go to Formula One with you because is that the same thing now?
It's just round and round.
And because if you sit in the stands and they just fucking drove in a straight
line,
it would be over in a minute.
So that's why they go around and around and around.
And then they would also have to clear out,
you know,
for 500 mile race,
if they had to clear up 500 miles of streets in a straight direction.
I mean all of a sudden you can't go from Mississippi to fucking the other side
of tax lien know in horse racing.
And I'm not saying that like horse racing is okay,
but you know how it's like go baby go and everyone's like,
yeah,
like chill,
like let's go,
let's go baby go.
There wasn't a lot of that.
Like people are on their phones.
People were eating crepes.
Like it was very like subdued.
Like there wasn't,
it didn't feel like there was a lot of action going on on a lot of excitement is
what I'm saying.
Cause it was 24 hour race
maybe too long.
Like maybe they shouldn't know.
I would say this.
What I thought I was amazing to me is that they had,
I counted,
I was saying this gotta be at least two classes if not three classes of cars out
there.
It turns out there was four different classes.
So I think there was like four winners in each class,
one for each class.
But we got there on the second day when we showed up,
there was two cars in the lead lap,
both Toyota's.
Um,
and the guy in first place was ahead by like a minute and a half,
which is like a,
you know,
that's like almost the back of the race than anything else.
And then the game third place was 12 laps down.
So I was Kinda like,
oh,
so this thing,
we this three hours to go and this is already over unless somebody crashes or
has a problem with their car.
And then the Toyota in second place did have a problem with this car briefly.
Um,
which put him even further back then he was down two laps and then,
um,
so yeah.
Um,
it's more of like an endurance thing.
I thought it was fascinating because um,
if I would recommend if you go to it,
go for the start or I would go at night just to see him at night.
It was kind of cool to see the brake lights and wipers and shit.
I've never seen that on race cars.
It's usually just like,
it's just a shell for a body with a rolled the whole full roll cage.
And it's just the powertrain that says
the wipers.
Yeah,
it was for me.
You know,
it's funny.
No,
no,
no.
You know what it is.
No,
it is.
Yes.
Steve McQueen and all that shit.
It was,
it was it just to know.
I mean people had died and the balls that it takes and all of that shit to do
it.
And uh,
I gotta be honest with you,
you know,
we were driving out there,
you will listen to you beyond saying you Jay z and then we got there and you
were on your phone the entire fucking time and it may be feel good about that
time I walked out when you were you,
you said you were quote in this play.
Um,
first of all,
that is not the same thing.
How dare you even make that comparison and I'll make it again.
Don't you yell at me on my own phone the whole time I was taking Instagram video
of you.
Okay.
And Instagram,
you and myself and the race I was on the whole entire time and I didn't walk
out.
Okay.
I wasn't like,
all right,
I'll,
I'll be in the car and say the same thing about that place.
I sat through the first half of it.
Were you in the 24 [inaudible] where are you in it?
Where you driving?
And I walked out.
No father's day.
No,
it's not the same thing I was,
I was the the narrator of that show and you walked out because you were like
bored and it was so rude and it really hurt my head,
I believe.
No,
you did it.
You did it for entirely selfish reason.
You were sitting right in my line of view and then we come back from
intermission and you're fucking gone.
And I can't even believe there was a white guy rapping and it was a play.
It's a towards things ever combined and I sat for 90 minutes of it and you're a
better actor than anybody there and all they had to do was go and later at the
hall of Justice,
it annoyed me.
I can't even believe that you would bring that up.
So many years later.
How long have you known me?
I'm going to bring that up.
So many years later after this.
You really are like the king of bringing back subway.
Yeah.
Remember back when and it's like we've been together for 15 years.
You're literally bringing up something from like year two of our relationship.
What else do I bring up from way back when?
Like a lot of stuff.
Oh good boy.
You're the king of making a big statement and then he can't back it up.
That's the fucking point of it is I am the God damn king.
Oh,
good one.
Take that to the bank.
No,
auto racing is he tortures thing to bring to somebody who doesn't give a shit
about cars.
We met that really Nice Guy,
Ryan hilly and he's the one who taught me how to say,
go fuck yourself.
What's that Brian?
Um,
he was really nice and he was very nice and he helped me out with my phones.
I enjoy,
I can't believe I went there.
Oh,
this is the,
here's a great one.
So Nia doesn't like beer.
There's no wine there.
So I keep buying two beers and it's like,
oh,
you don't want to finish that.
So I'm drinking daddy's having a good time on father's day.
Right.
So I bought a
crepes there,
but no wine.
I mean this is France,
but that's really,
it was grapes to them.
It's just suck a fucking sandwich.
That was really kind of,
what about the other guy?
Is it insulting if I say that it's like the Nascar France,
that's insulting because Nascar is not on the same level as 24 hour
Lamar.
Oh,
I don't know what you mean.
I think that you were more looking at it like you were outside Paris,
so there wasn't as many fancy clothes to people walking around.
Um,
I think that that sort of,
as you're very,
you,
you know,
you're a class kind of person,
like,
oh,
right here nor there.
I'm up here.
Interesting.
Because people are all my comments being like,
well,
I hope you are a nice little later.
It'll be,
didn't busy while,
or like,
you know,
what do they say to me?
Do they say that?
Yeah.
When every fucking week,
let me see.
I want to say I want the receipts even with the receipts.
Well,
I want Y'all fucking receipts then I'll show you myself coming here.
Like you,
the FBI dude going to turn over my laptop to you.
Um,
oh,
we have one.
Yes we did.
We had a great time over here and uh,
tonight we are seeing a guns [inaudible] roses tonight.
Uh,
it's hard to hold a candle in the girl November Ray.
That was good.
Thank you.
I've never seen them in concert,
so
it's going to be awesome.
So,
uh,
that's what we're doing and then we're going to look in and then we fly back.
I hope he says that.
How do you say that in French?
I thought you,
you learned that I want to learn this.
Um,
anyways,
I dunno.
I've been having a good time.
Ha Ha.
How I have been torturing people with my French,
haven't I?
Yeah,
I don't,
when they go to English,
I don't give a fuck.
It's like,
it's the most fun.
It's so much fucking fun to just,
uh,
just some French people will humor you,
but a lot of times they like can't be bothered.
Remember when,
um,
oh,
remember what was the rest of dropped we went to and we were having a hard time
figuring out the menu and uh,
I was saying,
so the guy,
I asked him,
I said,
oh,
can you translate some of this stuff for us?
And he goes,
oh,
I don't,
I just get you an English menu.
And I was like,
yeah,
okay.
And you were like,
oh no,
no.
I want to know sweat.
It's like,
Bill,
he doesn't want to sit here and translate the entire menu when it was an
English.
Hmm.
How does parents make their money?
Taurus.
Yeah.
Fucking humor me.
Okay.
But it doesn't work like that.
And you come over to my co dia huge day.
A little bit that you did that,
you know,
we miss,
it's walking down the street there.
I know they're all fucking,
don't,
don't pull that shit.
I don't,
I'm so sick of hearing that every fucking person who isn't from America is
fucking is the greatest person ever.
I'm walking right now.
Hang on a second.
Yeah.
I gotta go get my charger here.
When we're walking.
I'm always,
always spinning.
Always moving.
Kyle again.
Um,
I don't know what the fuck it is.
No,
no,
I don't,
I don't do that.
Okay.
People here in France or just like Americans.
Some of them are nice,
some of them are not,
and a lot of them are fat.
Okay.
Yeah,
there's a lot of fucking fag teacher again,
the maintenance man.
Okay.
Well Dot.
Again,
you genius.
Um,
all right.
Do you have anything else to add about how,
uh,
you know,
okay,
here's the thing.
All right,
so maybe you didn't do it to the level of walking out halfway through a play
with,
I want to reiterate again,
it's just in defense to my listeners.
It was a play and there was white guy rapping the entire time.
Okay.
And it wasn't M&M
eyebrows up like he was blowing my mind.
I set to 90 minutes of that
as you sat over in the fucking corner,
you get away later.
Paging Mrs. Herman
at the Front Desk.
Yeah.
What the fuck.
And then I went out to the stage directions because it wasn't a full production.
It was kind of like a re staged reading.
So I was,
it was a musical.
I don't sing.
So you know,
I was there doing the stage directions.
I got paid.
It was a Gig.
Okay.
Um,
I quoted the shit out of you.
I didn't make you own.
Wow.
I didn't walk out.
I went out and I had a Sam Adams and I was like,
and I came back,
wait,
let me finish.
And I sat down.
I was like,
fuck,
that was delicious.
That was as delicious as what I just saw was horrific.
And I was just like,
maybe if I stay out here,
she won't notice.
It was totally,
totally,
totally selfish.
And I have apologized and there'd be kids because of the guilt that I try to
bring you down to my level.
Oh wait.
And that's what it is because I love you so much.
Oh please.
And uh,
changed me the,
you know,
just because you know,
I do all these great things for you,
son of a gun.
When I learned what I learned it from,
I don't know.
I'm not going to,
you cry on cue.
Oh God.
Did you just try to be Sassy?
Yeah,
cases face.
I just felt like I was doing it.
Did they rebuilt good times?
What just happened there?
We'll be right back with white,
red,
black meaning fucking messages.
Anyway.
Wait,
read.
Um,
all right.
Are you going to miss this apartment?
I'm ready to go home after the gods are roses thing is going to be as perfect.
We're going to do that and then we fucking go home.
I ready to go back,
eat some keen to work,
get back on my diet,
hit the elliptical.
Oh,
you mean having croissants and baguettes every day?
So fucking good.
It's so good.
Yeah,
but you don't get as fat as if to eat them over there.
You know,
who makes them?
Howard Johnson,
who makes them in our country.
It makes the bag a couple of places in la that have really good and intimate
Pepperidge farm.
There's some good places that have amazing clusel,
but no,
not like here.
Okay.
All right.
Well thank you for coming out.
Let me,
let me finish this fucking thing.
Oh,
you're not done,
Huh?
No,
I'm only 23 minutes and this is usually when I,
when I butcher.
Oh God.
Are you sharing
your story?
All right.
Uh,
well,
you know certain certain people have to take a nap in here.
Oh,
well you told me to come in here and about an hour.
About an hour.
They do.
All right.
We'll get you walking out on the podcast the way I did on your play,
chase.
I guess we're even now.
Try it.
Oh my God.
Oh,
whoa,
whoa.
I'm a dumb.
Oh God,
Dude.
They're the fucking way was
that fucking blade was the worst.
Okay.
Oh,
this fucking kid jumped to do do with your p two p.
D.
Dot.
Up to doing the fucking thing with his hands.
Oh,
it was,
it was in a bar.
How fucking long are you supposed to sit there for that,
you know,
and she gets to go to a Goddamn car race and fucking sit there and
look up dancing with the stars.
Shit is,
I'm sitting there.
She clearly bored out of her fucking mind.
Bored out of her fucking mind at that fucking race.
Tough like fucking shoe leather that moves around.
Um,
all right.
Where the fuck is the advertising for this?
You know,
I'll never live down that I knew it.
it's so fucking stupid is if I just went back in for the final 90 fucking
minutes.
Um,
I'm the king of bringing up shit.
Yeah.
Anytime she's fucking brought that up to me.
Put it this way.
I've got yelled at that longer than the fucking play was.
All right.
Uh,
please don't read on air.
this is a note from somebody.
Host says he doesn't know what he's saying.
And at the end he offs advice that directly contradicts what he read.
They just ask that you not imply something.
Okay.
A right.
Everybody fucking relax.
He says Christ pay.
It's not about giving people information,
it's about it being entertaining.
All right,
policy genius.
If you have a car at what you,
you have car insurance,
if you have a home number is that you have home insurance.
If you are alive,
shouldn't you have life insurance?
Okay,
410 people don't have life insurance at all and it's not their fault.
It's not light.
It's life insurance is fault.
Shopping for life insurance is confusing and it takes forever.
So Pauli Genius made 80 g I don't even have good thing,
man.
Paulie genius is the easy way to compare life insurance online and just five
minutes.
You can compare quotes from the top insurers to find the best policy for you.
And when you compare quotes,
you save money.
It's that simple.
In fact,
Paulie Policy,
oh that Pauli gene policy genius,
it's the greatest policy ever has helped over 4 million people shopped for
insurance and placed over $20 billion in coverage and then I'll make life and
they don't make just make life insurance easy.
They also compare disability insurance,
renter's insurance and health insurance.
If you care about it,
they can cover it.
You've been putting off getting life insurance.
Don't put it off any longer.
You've got to do this stuff by the way,
especially you've got a wife and family,
you know you've got kids and shit.
You got to do it.
It's the greatest feeling.
I know it's weird,
you know,
contemplating your own mortality,
but after you did it,
you got that.
Hey,
you know,
if I die,
everybody's going to be good.
Be a fucking keg party.
It's a great feeling.
Unless you're married to a psycho,
it's never been easier to buy and rates are at a 20 year low policy,
genius.com the easy way to compare and buy Life Insurance Pol.
I see why Ge,
e I u s policy,
genius.com if you guys see that stupid commercial with that woman is just like
go and you know,
I had insurance on my car and you know when my wrecked my car,
they only gave me,
you know,
I pay 12 grand from my car and it's five years later and they only gave me six
four,
what am I supposed to do by half a car?
Now you had the wrong insurance.
I love it.
They act like,
you know,
there's two types of insurance.
You can get insurance,
that cheaper kind,
which is they're going to give you the money for the value of whatever the fuck
it is that you insured at that what it is at that time to appreciate it.
Or you can buy,
replace it new and that's going to cost you way more fucking money.
So that woman is yelling at the insurance company and the reality is,
is she's fucking naive.
Well she's just an actor.
Whoever wrote that fucking thing is,
is it's,
it's not like this,
this new insurance company that is now,
you know,
going to fucking give you 12 grand fee of $12,000 car 10 years after the body.
You're going to fucking pay for that.
All right?
And it's going to cost a lot of money.
And if you add up what the fuck he paid for it over the years,
it's really probably not that much of a difference.
Okay?
Simply safe,
everybody.
It's important to protect your hoe.
What the hub security system,
how can we protect your home and your privacy?
Uh,
that's what you're going to love about simply safe.
They obsess over details like no home security company.
Here's an example.
Simply safe has a camera you can control from your phone,
but they want to protect your home and your privacy.
So they came up with this brilliant idea,
a privacy shutter for their camera.
Now it's definitely safe wanting to you to be able to hear the shutter clicks so
you know it's closed.
They wanted it to have a light on it so you can easily tell when it's on.
They needed it to work for the entire lifespan of the system.
So simply safe.
Got To work.
Bomp bomp,
bomp,
bomp bomp bomp testing different males,
but what to do and hinge designs for months and months.
Does that really mean like door hinges?
We got to make it stop squeaking Bob about the pop,
Bup,
the result and effect of home security camera with a thin,
lightweight aluminum privacy shutter that will make every,
that will work every time.
It's that kind of attention to detail that sets simply safe apart and keeps your
family safe.
Simply safe isn't just home security.
It's home security done right checkout.
Simply save today.
It's simply safe bird.com that simply say [inaudible] dot com to learn more
about SIPI said day simply safe.com.
That's s I,
m P,
l,
I,
s a f e,
[inaudible] dot com.
All right,
there you go.
Well,
Bup,
bup,
bup.
All right,
um,
now where did all my questions go away?
More shawls.
Um,
all right.
So anyways,
oh my God.
I mean,
it's such a,
you want,
I made such a fucking ass of myself.
I've eaten so much French food.
Okay.
I got focused baguettes coming out of my fork and he is over here and I'm
growing a fucking bra on my hair.
Used to be okay.
And Betty opposed to walk up though.
So I up the street,
they had this,
uh,
they had a little pizzeria.
So Mike,
okay,
there's no way this pizza can be as bad as a pizza in la.
You know,
I know it's not gonna be as good as Italy.
Who gives a fuck,
right?
So I'm trying to find this place.
And what happens when you're in a country where you don't speak the language is
a lot of times you stop reading words and you just start looking at colors of
thanks.
And you start like,
um,
like anything yellow is a taxi.
Anything blue becomes a police car and like tat type of Shit.
So there was this restaurant with this red awning,
like the Italian restaurant,
and I'm looking at it going,
I dunno,
man,
it doesn't quite look right.
And rather than just reading
the French,
what does it [inaudible] or something like that,
whatever.
I went up to the guy and I was just looking at the menu and I was just,
you know,
I was just tired
and I couldn't find any pieces,
anything.
So finally I just,
this guy walks up to one of the fucking ways.
It's like,
you know,
Bone Juma,
showbiz.
It been a bit of dinner.
I am say Susan Wa,
uh,
is this a Italian restaurant?
And he just like goes cause like,
ah,
it's like no miss yet.
This is a French restaurant and he just fucking walked away.
I felt like such an asshole.
What does it a Brasserie,
whatever it means.
It's was written right there across the red on it.
And then it went one more block up and there's the red awning.
That was the Italian place.
Yeah.
And I wonder,
yell down.
Excuse me.
Yeah.
I was only off by a block.
Go Fuck Yourself.
But I know he was right.
And I went in and I ordered two pieces,
right?
I got the Margarita and then I got the one with the end.
Joe On it and a I gotta tell Ya,
it was fucking horrific or worse than the pizza in.
But the,
uh,
[inaudible] knee swat was a puff famous yet,
um,
was actually delicious.
But um,
I might have been to get through tonight.
I just,
I can't fucking do it anymore.
I stayed here just a couple of days too long,
but I got to see guns and roses.
You want to hear my whole fucking guns and roses story here?
Okay.
Uh,
the first time they came around in a city that I was in,
they were opening for Motley Crue,
the original lineup.
And I forget why I fucking miss that show.
All right.
And then,
um,
then they use your illusion tour came out and I had a ticket to see him on that
one.
And then one of my buddies,
you know,
the love of his life dumped him and he was fucking devastated,
borderline suicidal and he needed some sort of fucking light and his life.
So I said,
hey,
I got a ticket to guns and roses.
You Go,
you need it.
Cause I don't want to see a kill yourself.
And he said,
I appreciate that man.
And then,
you know,
all the drama happened,
and all the,
you know,
the whole band basically was just axle,
right.
And then they didn't talk for like 10 fucking years or something like that.
And by then I was a comedian.
I just stayed up.
And then when they got back together,
I had a hookup to go to the show at the fucking club there,
the troubadour there,
first time back together,
I had a ticket for that,
but I was working on the road.
I couldn't go every fucking time.
I've tried to see this band,
one of my favorite bands of all fucking time.
Um,
I,
I just,
something has always happened where I haven't been able to go.
So finally,
finally,
I'm going to see him tonight.
I can't fucking wait.
It's going to be a,
yeah,
that's not even going to be real until it starts happening.
That's how long you been waiting to see this frigging bent.
So anyways,
very excited about that animal.
So a great way to wind up a perfect trip and then get back to the states.
And do some standup because I have not done stand up in a couple of weeks.
All fucking Rusty Jones is going to limp on stage down to the comedy store later
on this weekend.
Probably try to get my fucking act back together.
So,
uh,
anyway,
so let's,
um,
my daughter has to take a nap.
My lovely daughter,
she's so cute.
She can say all these French words now we bone bone jewel.
Um,
why isn't this light working?
I can't even see him anytime I've done yet.
All right,
let's just read a couple of questions here.
Oh,
it's on 24 hours in a month.
Uh,
Lamar,
uh,
hey Billy Borgen y'all.
I just heard you say you were going to Lamar for,
of the race.
I'm from Cleveland,
but able to go
to the 24 hours twice when I happen to be in France for work the same week.
Not sure what your plans are there,
but had to let you know about an awesome hidden gem along the muscling straight.
My first time,
they're 2012,
a friend came out to meet me and we drove down the with essentially no plans.
Didn't have tickets or a place to stay that night.
We bought tickets at the gate and gone and just in time for the start.
Then ended up befriending and drinking with a group of Brits that lasted most of
the day.
Uh,
this is how you do it.
One of the outlets who,
when to do the next time.
One of them told us of a bar somewhere along the no way,
the ridiculously long straight that runs a few miles away from the area of the
track you get access to or you get access to what the ticket.
So him and the two of us decided to leave the track and catch a cab to try
finding it took forever seeking it out though.
Random back roads.
The streets you would usually get to it are on weight.
The street you would usually get to it on is the race track found out after the
fact.
The place is called.
I can't read this
or bearish there on the and was a great spot to eat,
drink while catching a short glimpse of cars at top speed just before the first
chicane.
I would definitely recommend seeking it out if possible.
But also I learned on my second trip there a few years later,
he should definitely make a reservation.
Maybe it's not so hidden anymore because it was too crowded to get in and they
only speak French if you call for one.
Uh,
we stayed there late into the night that first time.
Eventually one of the restaurant employees gave us a ride back to our car on the
other side of the track where we,
oh you,
you'd like stay there for the whole fucking race now we got maybe a couple hours
of sleep anyways,
just had to tell you about that.
That track is so crazy compared to anything.
You'll see an f one is definitely worth getting outside of the main area.
Whether you seek out that spot or somewhere else,
just to get an idea of how massive the track is and see them doing 200 miles an
hour down dark country roads with just their headlights to the track.
Not sure if you'll actually get this message before.
Uh,
I missed all of that.
I was on the main straightaway and it just looked like a regular race truck.
Um,
while I'll be like,
Yo,
the second time around,
hopefully I'll get it right.
God dammit.
I didn't know there was all of that,
a rejection letters.
You know what was crazy was there was a fucking airport like re like parallel,
like right.
Almost touching the main straightaway.
And I kept seeing these helicopters like taken off and shit.
You know,
I thought they were just following the race and now all of a sudden I sound like
a fucking Leer jet flying right along where a helicopter just been along.
I'm like,
there's no way that's fucking safe.
What is that all about?
Is that some rich guy just going,
I don't give a fuck.
I'm paying you buzz the fucking race track.
Okay.
We've around these fucking helicopters,
you know,
but turned out there was a,
um,
yeah,
there was a uh,
airport right there.
Um,
anyways.
Anyways.
Oh it is.
This one is this one.
I should bring Leah in here for this one.
Really rejection letters.
Psycho
bill wondering if you saw this.
This accomplished clarinet player was accepted to his dream school.
Okay.
Uh,
but never received the good news because his then girlfriend deleted it and sent
him a fake rejection email that turned out to be a $265,000 mistake on her part.
MMM.
Okay.
Let's see what the fuck happened.
Uh,
all right.
This kid,
his hard work paid off the accomplished clarinet had been accepted to his dream
school,
but he never got to hear the good news.
That's because when his acceptance email arrived in 2014,
his then girlfriend deleted it and sent him a fake rejection email from the
school.
Was it $265,000 mistake?
He said it was really
okay.
Devastating to feel that incredible betrayal.
It may be think of our whole relationship and made me feel like everything might
have been a lie.
Uh,
anywhere.
It began a college sophomore studying music at Mcgill University.
At the time,
this kid had applied to a two year full scholarship program to finish his
bachelor's degree at the Colburn Conservatory of Music in Los Angeles.
Itching to study with a renowned clarinet.
Teacher.
So-And-So spent many late nights in practice rooms to prepare for his audition,
which he thought went well.
The full scholarship,
which includes tuition,
room and board is worth about 50 grand a year.
And so and so said graduating from Colburn would have sent him up for a high Ph,
set them up for high paying symphony career.
When he was rejects this,
uh,
the kid was crushed.
It was disappointing feeling.
He said,
I had such high hopes,
uh,
the kid would,
would have studied with this person who was considered one of the best clarinet
instructors in the world.
Uh,
he said,
uh,
the school accepts only two students each year at Colburn,
and he was one of them.
Okay.
Um,
how she covered her tracks this Wednesday,
a Canadian court ruled that this guy's ex-girlfriend,
older more than $265,000,
350 grand Canadian for damages,
including loss of reputation,
educational opportunity,
and two years of potential income.
Roughly $37,000.
Can you fucking,
can you believe like the level
of like
breaking into is eat.
Like she had to be snowing,
that he,
that letter coming,
she had three constantly scan for her.
So much she knows his fucking,
I guess computer passwords.
It's just scanning and scanning saying finds it,
sees it.
He gets accepted.
Fucking delete this guy's dream and then comes up with a whole phony thing.
I don't even know.
I want to how the fuck they found out.
But this is why this,
this whole talk and you know this me too shit now where they're just saying
straight across the board believe women when there's women like that out there,
okay,
there's a reason why that there's due process and you,
you have to have evidence and you have to listen to both sides of the fucking
story.
Yet again,
another person was accused this week and without the person being accused,
without them ever responding this,
this stuff that people wrote on Twitter,
I always knew this person was a piece of shit.
Uh,
I love one person was a fucking most self serving thing ever.
If you still fall in so and so,
unfollow me,
right?
Like,
like,
wow,
man,
you're really sticking up for women.
You're willing to lose,
to lose like fucking Twitter followers way to make a fucking stair stop making
it about yourself.
You fucking jerk off.
Um,
and I'm not saying anybody innocent,
guilty or whatever.
Uh,
the reality is then the guy then responds and says,
no,
look,
we argued and blah,
blah,
blah.
And she ended up being unfaithful to me and I didn't want to be with somebody.
That one that was unfaithful to me.
So then at that point,
I just want to know like,
how does,
how does anybody make a judgment?
Any sane,
rational person?
Like you read her story like,
wow,
man,
that's really fucked up,
blah,
blah.
And then you read his thing.
It's like,
oh,
well then there's that side of it.
So then what
you just now at that point,
you've read two things online.
Like just imagine a court in a court of law.
Uh,
somebody like entire future was on the line and the plaintiff and the defendant,
all they were going to do was write two paragraphs of,
I don't know if you'd call it a blog or whatever,
and then you are going to determine,
you know,
somebodies ability to continue their career or not.
Is,
is I,
am I,
that's a little fucking nuts.
People,
and this is what's driving me up the wall is I've been saying this,
it's shows and you know,
the vibe is,
people fucking agree with that,
but everybody's afraid to say it.
So it's just,
I know,
it's just not a,
uh,
this,
you know,
this shit that guys had been doing,
a women has to fucking stop.
But I don't think the way to go about it is to just make blanket statements of
believe women.
Like it's like all of them.
Even the ones who keep people's cars and fucking
break laptops and destruction of property,
all of that.
Even the ones that fucking,
you know,
are out there saying that they love somebody just cause the guy's got fucking
all of them.
I don't know.
It's really,
it's a little fucking,
uh,
it's,
it's just such a fucking,
I never heard it.
I can't,
I why out of all is,
I'm just really surprised at how fucking,
just how afraid everybody isn't.
Hi.
Everybody just chooses self preservation and they'll sit there and they'll watch
somebody twist in the wind.
You know,
cause there's been,
you know,
there's been the ones that are obviously like this guy's a fucking monster,
this guy should be in jail.
And then there's been some other ones like what?
And it,
but everybody's still shuts the fuck up while these loan,
it ticks on Twitter or like,
you know,
fucking burn him at the stake.
Um,
I dunno,
I keep thinking that eventually,
like it's,
it's Kinda like calm down a little bit where people are going to be like,
okay,
yeah,
what if that what that woman wrote is true.
This needs to happen.
Why don't we all just hang on a second and listen to what the guy has to say it.
And then even then all you've done is just,
it's,
that's like you show up at a fucking car accident
and it both drivers at point at each other
and you know,
and you weren't there when it fucking happened.
I don't know.
That's another thing too,
when you watch all of these,
like these,
these videos and shit of,
of,
you know,
injustices happening.
What I can't stand about those fucking videos is it always starts asked for the
most part after the injustice happened and it's one person's point of view on it
and everybody just watches it and acts like they just saw a documentary or
actually just watched the footage from beginning to end.
Um,
or maybe it isn't.
Maybe it's just a 30,000 fucking lunatics on,
on social media.
I have no idea.
But,
uh,
I dunno,
like Nia,
show me one the other day and I was just watching going like,
all right,
well what she's bitching about it isn't on this,
the footage,
it's just her yelling at the guy saying,
why did you do that?
You didn't see him do what she's saying that he did and he standard at defendant
himself saying,
I didn't fucking do it,
but it's her video.
So her point of view becomes what happened.
This is getting confusing to me.
Just trying to fucking explain it to you.
Um,
anyways.
All right.
28 year old virgin.
Hey Billy,
Billy bill blaster.
Uh,
I love the podcast and you're raging sanity.
I'm going to be honest,
I don't think there's a solution to my problem.
Oh,
come on man.
But just hearing you talk about it might help me see it as a so bad.
It's funny kind of situation.
Uh,
I'm a 28 year old virgin and he rides in,
oh Geez.
I'm ugly as shit.
I'll come on man.
Except even shit has dung beetles that appreciate the aesthetic.
Alright,
so you got a sense of humor.
Self deprecating.
I got big ass ears that lie perpendicular to the side of my head.
Big Triangle,
nose,
balding island patterns,
small.
Oh,
island of hair on the forehead.
Uh,
with the rest of the hair in a horse shoe pattern.
Very hairy all over.
Except my fucking head pointy ass man,
titties with Pepperoni Nipples,
Jesus Christ.
And Best of all my genitals alone would send any woman's sprinting towards the
horizon
side from that.
Can't complain.
Respectable job.
Good friends,
great family,
bit heavy,
five,
nine,
160 pounds.
Dude,
that's not heavy.
Uh,
but otherwise healthy.
Um,
I tried to stay upbeat,
but I,
as I get older,
it really starts to weigh on me that I'm destined to live life,
uh,
on as a solo player.
Any advice would be appreciated.
Wish you and your family all the best.
Uh,
yeah.
Dude,
come on man.
You got to step up to the plate.
All right.
You're,
you're saying game over before you even play the game.
All right.
Yeah.
You have a great sense of humor.
I think you're being way too hard on yourself.
Uh,
the fact that you say you're a bit heavy at five,
nine,
one 60,
uh,
you know,
I think you're being,
you means to me that your prop,
yet you're not heavy,
which means you're probably not nearly as ugly as you're saying.
MMM.
Yeah,
dude,
I would get out there.
There's this dating apps,
there's all kinds of shit you can do.
MMM.
I mean,
I,
you know,
you got any friends,
any guy friends?
Just tell him just like,
dude,
I'm a 28 year old fucking virgin.
You've got gotta help me out here.
Okay.
Maybe that's not the way to go because guys will fucking be like,
try to just find you some,
you know,
loose woman.
That's not,
I don't think that's the way you want to go.
MMM.
But I,
I,
yeah,
I would just,
you gotta you gotta get up to the plate too.
You got to get up to the plate and you have to stop looking at yourself the way
you look at it yourself.
Um,
you got to keep that great sense of humor,
but you know,
you're not ugly as shit.
Okay,
dude,
look at me.
Okay.
I'm a fucking 50 year old balls,
redheaded male,
and I think I look great.
It's all how you look at yourself.
Okay.
But if you think you look good,
you feel good about yourself,
it's a nice vibe to fucking have and you'll attract people.
All right?
And just your sense
that I've been number one thing you got going for yourself is a stipend fact.
You still have your whole life ahead of you.
You're only 21 and 28 years old.
You got a great sense of humor.
Women love to laugh.
Huh?
How do you think I landed mia?
I made a fucking left.
Sure as hell wasn't comes from my fucking looks.
Um,
I don't know what it was.
Who the fuck knows?
But if she knew 15 years later,
she'd be going to the 24 hours a month.
I don't think she would've gone.
You landed me because I knew about your earning potential.
That's it.
What?
Oh my God.
Hey Nick.
Hey,
just kidding.
Um,
I loved you long before any of this.
Any of one.
I was making money when you met me.
No,
you weren't.
Yes,
I was.
I was on the rich bitch tour.
Right.
But like,
you weren't rich bitch all.
Sorry.
I was doing great anyway.
Yeah.
I never,
I never told you.
You never told me.
I didn't ask.
I didn't care.
Like it's just,
Oh wow.
It's amazing.
You can just came in here and became a hero.
No.
Hey,
can you help this guy out?
He's a 28 year old virgin.
Ask you about your mind.
You said he's a 28 year old version.
That's fine.
And he goes,
I'm ugly as shit.
Oh.
He goes,
except even shit has dung beetles that appreciate that.
The aesthetic.
Oh Sweetie,
what do you see?
What you got?
But he's got a great sense of him.
He goes,
I've got big ass.
Here's at light.
Perpendicular to the side of my head.
Big Boat as well.
Smith,
big triangle nose.
[inaudible] I know that.
That boy.
Yeah.
What about Adrian Brody,
you like,
Oh yeah,
there you go.
Got a big ass Roman nose.
Balding island pattern.
You know when you've got this circle here with the Horse Shoe,
shave it all off.
A
very hairy all over except my fucking head.
He goes pointy ass man.
Titties with Pepperoni nipples.
This sounds like Jim Norton wrote this and best of all it goes.
My genitals alone would send any woman's sprinting towards the horizon.
Oh,
got a little one.
Okay.
Wow.
All right.
So what does he do?
That little one.
Listen,
I,
I know they say,
listen,
I know they say that the man makes the gloves,
the gloves.
I'll make the man.
But I feel like,
you know,
maybe the need to shave that head bald like the way bill has it.
So you know,
there's no like trace.
Anytime that horse shoe starts to come back,
you just slap some shaving cream on it and go to town on that bad boy.
Why do people think know like MMA or some shit?
Watch your back.
Cause that shits nasty.
Just waxing it.
Just boom.
Just deal with it.
You'll be fine.
Um,
a lot of these already.
60% better looking right there.
Yeah.
Go.
You know,
get,
go to the gym,
you'll feel,
nevermind.
Five,
nine,
one six.
He said,
he says,
he goes,
I'm a bit heavy.
Five,
960 doesn't sound big to me.
That sounds maybe or deli,
maybe your fleshy.
Lashey maybe you're skinny fat like you're not,
you don't have any tone in your body.
Yeah.
Not My temple,
not my son ball.
So here's what he does.
He shaved his head,
shaved his head for he gets shredded.
No,
for the women she had get shredded itself cause they'll feel better about
himself.
Just even going to the gym.
You'll make himself feel better.
I mean,
I don't know what to do about your Dick size.
I mean I hope your ETL game is strong because,
so what if he had like a 12 pack apps you get with the guy 12 pack abs.
Well APEC would of Apac.
ABS is necessary.
You don't need to know.
Wait,
can you let me finish with the scenario eight pack abs that you kissed down.
That leads to is a little fella down there.
Are you?
You'd be less disappointed if he had the little fucking xylophone above it,
but you go to who didn't grow up on the scene.
It was certainly help.
Maybe you should also like cut down your pubes so your Dick looks bigger
but he doesn't need his dick is in small.
He five nine one 60 Pete fucking thinks he's fat.
I bet his dick is fine.
I don't know.
He says it small.
So listen,
some guys aren't blessed and that's fine.
That's why I'm saying your ETL gained better.
Be Strong.
You eat out game,
you're fingering game,
all that stuff.
Ass eating,
whatever.
Just
I don't know what,
I don't even know who you are right now.
Don't tell him he needs to get a 12 pack left.
Too intimidating and just go to the gym.
Like not everybody has to have washboard abs.
I've just,
you just fucking told this guy that you know all of these fucking skills,
like when you first get laid all you know,
and now you're doing all these fucking,
you know,
next level move.
So those are all next level moves,
right?
Oh and act out.
I wouldn't say fingering though.
Yeah,
that,
that's a pre,
that's the prequel.
That's like the third star wars.
Right?
Listen,
as long as he knows where the clit is,
he'll be fine.
Right?
Yeah.
I would think with videos and shit and all,
everything on the Internet,
I think it'd be fine.
But don't use porn as a guy and a point like,
I just feel like Warren in guys up because like you are,
I'm not saying to use porn.
So should he go to a
dot.
Clinton signs?
Quick Binder,
clip finder?
Uh,
no.
This is where you save your money and you get a nice professional woman who can
like help you with all of that.
That's not the ideal way to lose your virginity.
But yeah.
Are you saying to get a hooker and escort,
you know,
hooker and an escort?
I Dunno really.
But escort sounds nice chance of STD.
Well,
I mean,
you know,
the escorts have like websites and stuff
on Venmo.
It's not like cash.
I mean,
cash is preferred
outside.
Like those people when they try and get you to go into the place to get your
taxes done out there,
flipping the signs around.
Okay.
Not that I have a problem with the street hookers either listen,
dad do what you gotta do.
Uh,
but he just needs a little guidance and low self esteem.
I don't know.
I feel like this is weird because it's like I'm promoting prostitution.
Yeah.
I think what I said was a little more positive.
I said go on dating sites and stuff like that and you can use your sense of
humor.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
The escorts.
Escorts.
I'm sorry.
No,
because I,
you know,
feel like sex workers are fine and whatever.
Um,
yeah.
But what's this question?
He wants to get laid.
Oh,
he wants,
he doesn't want to go through life alone.
Of course.
None of us do.
My suggestions.
Like what more,
what more what?
You know,
nothing.
Nothing.
You want to do the last one here.
You were on a roll.
Here you go.
You're fucking killing it.
And there's this whole level of coldness to you today.
That's really funny.
We talked about that last night.
Oh yeah.
Uh,
what do you,
what are you over you over the podcast or something?
No,
no,
no.
Oh,
but no,
it just might coldness.
It's just like,
you know what I have to do to survive.
It's called world baby.
All right.
Mr Friend's mom is a Seiko.
Mr Friends,
this sounds like a TV show.
Mr Friend's mom is a psycho.
Ah,
dear bill,
I have a friend who's been getting grounded a lot recently for the dumbest shit.
Does that mean my friend's mom?
Not Mr friend's mom
probably,
but I liked Mr friend's mom better.
All my friends have known for a while that his mom was a psycho,
but now it's getting way worse.
First he got grounded for a month.
How old is this person?
Yeah,
I was gonna say it wasn't allowed to leave the house outside of school at all
because he got a 70 on one test.
His grades are good,
not great,
but better than 70% of the kids at my school.
Um,
now,
just this past week,
he got grounded for the entire summer for using his laptop to text when he
wasn't supposed to be able to communicate with anybody outside the house when
he's not in school.
He's 16 years old,
by the way.
Is there anything I could do,
could or should do to help him or should I just leave it alone?
You got to leave it alone.
Yeah.
You're not the parent,
just be his friend and just commiserate with him.
How nick,
he's grounded for the whole summer down.
He can't leave the house or like anything like that.
No.
I know what I would do,
but I'm not giving a minor advice.
Exactly.
That's probably,
yeah.
I'm going to stay away from this one.
Moving on.
By the way,
70% is not acceptable on a test.
He didn't see.
He said his grades are good.
They're not great.
He's kind of agreeing with you.
Yeah.
He's just saying this not justification.
One text message,
you can't go off the whole summer.
He know about parenting or any of that stuff.
You're too young.
Do you think so you think that's a fair getting on?
We've got a 70 on a test to ground them.
No,
I don't communicate with your friends outside of school and then he sent one
text message or whatever and now he can't go off for the whole summer.
That's definitely extreme.
I don't think that I would parent like that,
but that's not my kid and I don't know what else he's doing.
I also don't know if it was just one text he sent one text.
Yeah.
What was the text about?
We're leaving that alone.
What does it say?
I'm going to stop one minute and 26 27 okay.
That's one hour.
One hour and 20 you think we'd done a minute?
We did a minute on this podcast and wrap it up.
Okay.
What a minute you said.
I said how much time have I done?
You said one minute.
One hour.
Okay,
cool.
Um,
all right,
well that's the,
yeah,
that's the podcast.
Knee.
I've had such a wonderful time here with you.
This is our place and that's right.
That's right.
And then we got to bring the baby.
Like how special is that?
I told you I was in the kitchen and I was like cleaning up and I was looking
over at her playing in the living room and I was like,
no,
I was making your dinner.
I was like,
I'm making dinner for my little baby girl and parent,
like just,
it's so special.
So I'll cool it when she says a French word.
Oh my God.
Say We'd,
she goes,
we lead irritated or when she says,
uh,
say thanks.
Yeah,
she nods her head.
She asked for food.
You Go,
what are you saying?
She goes,
and then he'd give it to you.
Now you're saying,
she goes,
she nods her whole head like a bad commercial for the 1950s.
It's the cutest thing ever.
Anyways.
Um,
that's it.
A messy,
bold,
cool,
messy book.
Cool.
Petty was blah bone.
We had a great time.
And,
uh,
that's it.
And thank you once again to Tom Rhodes for letting me know about that
Patisserie.
Or You just had the,
uh,
the pistachio Maca Room.
You got to have those sandwiches.
I got,
I got the fucking,
uh,
he's young born of that for a mileage.
Oh.
Oh No.
I gave you a half of each thing and I got a salmon one.
Cool.
They're like,
punch the wall.
Good.
Fucking incredible.
All right.
That's the podcast.
Uh,
oh,
I got to say it in I gonna
I gonna say,
keep forgetting how to say,
go fuck yourself.
I keep,
forget how to say,
go fuck yourself.
I'm [inaudible] Var to fair UNCW.
Lay.
I'll,
ah,
I'll check in on you on Thursday.
Fuck.
Do I shut it off?